Bruce Allen the president in Washington
and Dave Kettleman the GM of the Giants
a little bit of a back and forth maybe
starting and I like the fact that the
Giants in Washington each have rookie
quarterbacks were going to be paying
close attention to how they develop and
there's this storyline that Dave
Gettleman put out there about that his
fear because he knew for a fact that two
teams between 6 & 17 the two spots where
the Giants had first-round picks two
teams were going to take Daniel Jones if
the Giants didn't take number six I
don't believe it I've never believed it
I think that he's masking the reality
which is he was afraid someone was gonna
leapfrog them at number 16 and take
Daniel Jones because they let everyone
know they wanted Daniel Jones
it's their own fault they had to take
him at number 6 but if you say that then
you do get run out of town but Bruce
Allen appearing on NFL Network responded
by basically saying he doesn't know what
our draft board is how does he even
begin to know what our draft board is I
don't know which draft board he knows
but he doesn't know ours and look it's
not a full-blown like WWE style feud yet
but I kind of like where this is going I
like a little war words I like a little
over the top I want to stir it up hey
come on let's see what Dave gentlemen
has to say in response to Bruce Allen I
mean he's been talking to the media 50
times this week let's have 50-1 come out
and say what you have to say about Bruce
Allen and maybe we can maybe we can make
this nice and spicy and interesting as
the season approaches I always like a
good rivalry too I don't think there's
enough personal rivalries in the NFL
anymore as compared to the old days of
the 80s and early 90s when you know of
course players and and organizations
there wasn't free agency in the salary
cap so people stayed with the
organization for a long period of time
and the rivalries were great during that
time period at least in my opinion
because it was personal you know it
really was you got to see the same guy
who beat you you know the last three
years it's year four and gosh we got to
play this guy again I'm sick of losing
to him
so I'm always for that the adds a little
juice a little spiciness like you said
but the big thing is and I said this a
little bit when we did the TV show it's
really we're getting them got himself in
trouble but as was his phrasing here you
know don't say you know for a fact okay
come on we know you
know for a fact that's where he really
messed up and opened up a can of worms
here you know opens up a can of worms
for one people like you and me and other
media members to go oh wait you know for
a fact all right let me call every team
between seven and sixteen in the NFL
Draft between the Giants having their
two bigs and let's see if they actually
were gonna take a Daniel Jones so
everyone does that you know when you say
for a fact you leave yourself open for
Bruce I'm gonna take a shot you know
across the bow like he did there so
that's really the big thing we're get
him and got himself in trouble don't say
that you would have he would have been
perfectly fine if he just said you know
hey we were really scared there was a
few teams that like quarterbacks and we
just didn't know who they wanted and we
knew Jones was our guy and we were
scared that he was at the top of the
board from one of those other teams if
he just said that it would have been all
done everybody would have accepted it
and we still wouldn't be talking about
it here three days later I think he used
for a fact to slam the door on the
discussion because if you peel the onion
enough you eventually get to the point
where people realize it's your own damn
fault you couldn't take him in 17 if you
shut your mouth maybe you keep him now
let me flip this around though because
even though from time to time we say the
Giants have a little bit of an attitude
maybe this little arrogance there
they're not sufficiently arrogant to
think they were the only team that loved
Daniel jump right right and and maybe
another team out there is keeping their
mouths shut nobody knew the Jaguars
wanted Blake bortles when they drafted
him so that's where you needed to be
concerned that you're gonna get jumped
or that there really is somebody because
they're not gonna tell you after the
fact that they wanted the guy they're
gonna say they got the guy they wanted
because there's nothing good that comes
from saying there was someone else they
wanted more than the guy they got but
because the Giants felt compelled Chris
and you were all over this they felt
compelled to make everyone think that
this was coming so they they wouldn't
get killed even worse than they did get
everyone comfortable with the idea that
Daniel Jones is gonna be the pick then
you have to take him at six you can't
wait until 17 or you are gonna lose him
that's the truth
there's no way Dave gentlemen can say
that yeah no you're right yes I mean you
know I guess they made a decision at
some point the last few weeks that that
was their guy that's what they wanted
and it seemed like they were her intent
on trying to sell that on the fan base
and again I'm not gonna get mad at them
for taking the guy they wanted at number
six whether I think he's worth it or not
I don't
you know I mean it doesn't matter what I
think but hey obviously he was scared of
the Washington Redskins a little bit and
we've heard rumors that Daniel Jones was
very high on their board I mean in fact
we've hearing rumors that really the
coaching staff had sounded like wanted
Daniel Jones and there was just a few
other people in higher up positions that
wanted Wayne Haskins that's a rumor that
is out there in NFL Ville I'm sure Dave
Gettleman heard the same thing too I'm
sure he was also a little concerned
about Denver at 10:00 just going I don't
know exactly who John Elway has at the
top you know maybe he got caught wind
that Daniel Jones was towards the top of
their board as well so I get his thought
processes on this whole thing
he's just kind of talked himself into a
few corners here to get himself in
trouble and it's easy to justify taking
the guy at six if he's your guy just
take him at six don't spend that hour
and a half of your life worrying that
he's not gonna be there and then it's
gone and then you're screwed if he's
your guy go get him
that maybe that's the better explanation
forget about waiting he's our guy Yeah
right I don't want to wait 11 spots and
lose our guy I don't know who's gonna
take him he's our guy and he's our guy
at six he's our guy at 17 he's our guy
at 1 if we'd had the first overall pick
that's what you have to say so I don't
know I just get them and got himself
twisted up like a pretzel with all the
media appearances he's done I have a
feeling he won't be doing this show but
that's ok we'll get by another guy who
won't be doing this show is Bruce Allen
we I think we gave up trying to get him
on the program but yeah I don't know
what his deal is I don't know Bruce
you've been mean do let me just let me
peel back the curtain yeah since we're
not on the air I can tell this little
story I don't think they liked the fact
that I won't say their name I know you
will and you you can you can say it if
you want they don't like the fact that I
won't say their name and I won't say
their name out of respect to the
percentage and there is a real
percentage a concrete percentage of
Native Americans who are genuinely
offended yeah by the use of that term
right and to me that's enough to not say
it and and it's not like I'm gonna pick
it outside of FedEx Field I'm not
writing a column every day saying they
should get rid of their name I just
choose not to use it right and it drives
people crazy how dare you not use it
it's name of the team well so what if
there's somebody whose name I don't like
or if I can't pronounce her name I'm not
gonna use it I mean I still acknowledge
that the person exists I just choose not
to use the name and I have a reason for
it
I'm not being mean I'm not being
vindictive I'm being fair to the people
who are actually offend there are people
you know even if the Washington Post
poll that they did a few years ago that
ended the debate at least for now that
only 10% of Native Americans were
offended by the term that's enough for
me one out of ten is enough so it should
be zero out of ten you know hey if
you're comfortable having a team that
has a name that offends people that's
fine it doesn't offend enough to change
it that's fine it still offends some so
I don't use this help anyway long story
barrel no that's Bruce Allen won't do
the shot that's why we won't get Jay
Gruden that's why we won't get daniel
snyder that's why you know and that's
fine I'll gladly make that sacrifice in
order to properly respect the 10% or
however many of the Native Americans
that find that term offense I shouldn't
say it either I did get disappointed in
myself I'm not telling you not to but I
don't I don't believe in it either
you're right I mean I wouldn't certainly
go up to a Native American and call them
that name and go hey yeah you know hey
your [ __ ] like this I know that's
offensive that's that's I'm not going to
do that that makes no sense at the
baseline that's where the issue is
you're not gonna do that so then you
shouldn't say the name I need to be
better at that and really the Washington
franchise needs to figure out another
name they need to figure out and talk to
the Native Americans
something that they feel is more
respectful to what they are what they
did how they contributed to this country
and move on with it because I am with
you the name is it's mean it doesn't
make sense I think I think I've stirred
up Captain Planet yes you have this
could this could get interesting yes the
tune in the next Chris Sims on button I
have a feeling a rant is coming
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports